hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play The
Crooked Man now a lot of you guys were
saying well lot of you guys were very
angry at my stupidity in the last one
but like guys you were saying that the
other option led to a bad end so I
wanted to just test it out really quick
to see like what this was because a lot
of people seem to be curious as to what
I missed
what's wrong are you sick or no you're
gonna cry you gonna cry like a little
baby you gonna cry you gonna cry little
baby girl ok so anyway so what's gonna
happen is I'm gonna get through this
until I get to the choice and when I do
get to the choice I'm gonna choose
please don't cry
because somehow that leads to a horrible
ending how I don't know let's find out
please don't cry crying won't do any
good I know all too well how you feel
but it may be tough but you have to move
on you know that don't you you can to
keep on going like this I'm sure someone
will understand you someday like me so
please don't cry you won't even let me
cry you won't even let me cry there's
really nothing I can do this is your
treasure I found it in the courtyard
earlier you decided to forget everything
right
dot-dot-dot I'm sorry I was selfish I
know better than anything that I can't
keep going on like this
I can't keep stewing over it I need to
forget him well that's all she me it's a
precious memory but I don't need it
anymore do I
this seems like good healthy stuff I'll
be going now
sorry I couldn't help you David I hope
you find what you're looking for huh
yeah thanks [ __ ] be well what oh he's
doing more than touching her Oh
ha ha ha bad and one what a [ __ ]
oh yeah and just non-stop not forgetting
is better somehow
what really okay anyway back into the
game this will be really easy to get
back where I was so a lot EU seemed to
get really upset with me and how stupid
I was and what you need to do is you
need to go to Ray's room because ray
laid down the stuff into a pattern that
I didn't write down holy [ __ ] wait where
was it
hey and it was the code must be girl I
didn't even write it down at that stupid
I haven't even gotten a chance to do it
you guys just told me that that's what I
need to do where was it it was over here
right no where was it
hmm uh yeah I was over here wasn't it
maybe here
no that's locked up but this one it was
in the parlor that I unlocked maybe yeah
there was okay so I need to write this
down because sorry I'd never do anything
beforehand why would I
okay so it's 1 0 1 0 1 1 1 1 1
and that is um there's 1 2 3
nada I don't know I don't know what it
is I don't even care what it is but I
got it 1 0 1 0 1 1 1 1 1
okay I got it I need to look at some of
these things abstractly so that is Ray's
passcode to the thing which I can
translate from binary to anything else
easy I'm pretty sure that's wait Joe Joe
one you want me to yeah yeah one I want
you to watch them do five two five five
six seven one six one one one one
number one is 15 okay got it got it 15
so it's 2 515 two five one five got it
that took me way longer than it should
have
okay all right I got it though a key
contained to the Reference Room did that
say what was that wait what reference
key reference give me I'm about to die
The Crooked Man is in my throat so I
need to go find the Reference Room which
is
wasn't it blue what what happened oh I
fell down the stairs what huh who'd you
be what are you doing in the school you
shady punk oh so just another guys in
the band in school some what shady punk
I'm just looking for someone this
doesn't make any sense dudes and
dudettes you shoved me out of a blue who
are you give me a name or I'm calling
the police on you what are you a teacher
here
David Hoover I'm looking for a guy who I
think was here I'm not a robber or
anything you sure as if a robber would
say they were one what do you want a
permit now you tell me who you are if
you're gonna ask me I'm Dee I graduated
from this school so I came back to bring
back some memories
[ __ ] Bowl bull honkey you did not
you're not real dee that's your name not
actually the oddest one I've heard but
it's a nickname dummy you think I'd like
some shady guy my real name yeah what a
little brat but I guess you ain't stolen
anything yet I'm just wandering so don't
mind me in my hip-hop ways smell yeah
mmm go suck an egg what the hell's his
problem didn't even apologize
he pisses me off am I in the second
floor yeah anyway I think the reference
room was somewhere around here was this
in Hey
right here okay so we're going in the
Reference Room and oh my god look on the
table first they say that people despise
those who think similarly to them and
who are in similar circumstances but
humans are curious in that they can hide
any outward appearance of goodwill or
hatred though they are to face deep down
they can make that idea unthinkable you
may despise someone you like much like
you but you may in your heart have
affection for them the improbable is not
impossible
ah okay all right then
books on international law books on
international law criminology
criminology yeah man okay way was this
record of books checked in or out okay
doesn't help me civil law so much law
why's there so much law how did that kid
graduate from here it seems like a giant
douche how do you know anything Oh
anything here no I can't even go this
way hello good with 1726 I'm gonna write
down those two numbers just because I
can
17:26 to 1806 signatory of the
Declaration of Independence father of
American law attached to the wall but
the screws a little use do I have the
screwdriver I do I do I just so happened
to pick the right one there's writing
behind the 1647 okay I'm running that
down as well 1647 I'm crossing out the
other ones there because they're
probably not necessary but I got another
code glad I took the screwdriver though
I'm not sure it'll be useful again I'll
replace it with whatever tool I didn't
get books on comparative Judas prudence
elephants for carrying books to the
basement no power so it doesn't work
shelves on the basement of her staff
only those who require books from the
basement must sign a form and be
accompanied by staff taking any
materials out is prohibited so I need to
find where this code goes to but first I
need to exchange the screwdriver for
something else where was that I think it
was on this floor right toolbox maybe it
was on the first floor no I was on this
floor there we go okay so I need to
replace I need to take the crowbar and
the hammer and leave the screwdriver
okay so now that I got that I have no
idea where I need to go
ah oh um there were more locked doors
down here this door was locked I don't
have the key for down and this room is
where the wire I was so I'm not sure
that it's on this floor I'm going to go
any meeny miney moe catch a tiger by the
toe if he hollers let him go eeny meeny
miny moe
upstairs okay we're going to go upstairs
first and check out these rooms uh this
is where I found the other thing what's
this one okay have I been in here some
sort of diary loss to know what the masu
security password couldn't get a
computer room headmaster got angry at me
this is the worst maybe I left it in a
book somehow okay so I andrew has the
same ID as his password so he left it in
a book maybe he left it in the Reference
Room and therefore this would be oh it's
not even let me put it in so obviously I
don't have it [ __ ] I thought it was on
to something there damn it I almost had
it on the first try
Callie okay what about you
hello nope no prompt here fine screw you
how about here six digit PIN about you
are you gonna be the one yes yes sixteen
it's obviously easy when it just prompts
me that I have one yeah key to the
lecture hallway alright alright we're
gonna make good [ __ ] okay I wasn't
explaining that one holy crap
what is the Crooked Man here oh oh I
thought I killed you dead but apparently
not if I did the other ending and I saw
you alive okay back in the hotel I I
thought I killed it but you didn't that
was brutal
okay uh god I think about it later got a
rule
none get gonna run around here which way
you gotta go which way you're gonna go I
got you
okay he's pretty fast yeah he was pretty
darn fast there what the hell am I
supposed to do where am I supposed to go
I have no idea I really have no idea
where I'm supposed to go ah okay well
what room am I even in do I have a key
I did it again Oh Oh what am i do i do i
bash it over the head with something
do I have a knife I don't know who I am
a knife
I thought I funny oh I might be in
trouble here uh some sort of notebook
excuse me crooked man while I read this
notebook here who is so interesting okay
I'm done so uh we're just gonna play
peekaboo here for a while Hey how's it
going yes
I'm gonna look dull Thank You out maybe
I have the key and I can lock it like
Vigo I'm not well I mean you just gonna
stand there oh yeah I'm getting it I'm
thinking outside the box I'm getting
guys all these puzzle games I'm getting
it everyone high five right now three
two
boom did you get it you missed it well
all right one more time
three two one wah boom all right thank
you everybody for indulging me I mean
back at the hotel hotels hours away
isn't it could it really be following me
why how damn it this is making me nuts
you're already crazy and you probably
know you are the thing then again it did
attack [ __ ] so it can't be my
imagination it exists monster that it is
but yeah Dee suddenly appears Yeah right
I don't even think sissy's real I don't
think Dee is real I think the crooked
man is David okay anyway so I got
through that just fine because I am a
Baus so I need to go down to the lecture
hallway which is where I just got the
key to so I will be on my way I believe
that this is it right here use the
lecture hall a key oh boy
oh god it's a series of tubes it's it's
it's not a big truck it's not something
you can just dump all over it says Oz
Harry's at ohms okay got a scrap from a
notebook the rule matches the other
pages so he was here many hopes were
fulfilled here many use were blessed but
I didn't receive that blessing what's so
bad about me I was never picked by
anyone it never made sense I loved those
days he had a leaflet for this school it
was in the desk felt like it was
important was he trying to be a lawyer
like Dee was I don't understand how
you're being a lawyer so young but
whatever maybe they're older than I
think they
okay sorry [ __ ] saver [ __ ] saver
okay keyhole painted over I don't even
understand that okay what do we got here
there's something on here no apparently
there is not okay is there anything
important here maybe I need to find
another oh it's completely dark out okay
maybe I need to find another scrap of
paper that kind of leads me like a clue
and a map like in the other one okay
keyhole painted over that's no good
okay so locked keyhole painted over and
Oh what what's going on today we plum
what oh he's looking at an old
graduation tape or something those who
passed our bar exams those who didn't
those who become clerks or notaries are
teachers all of us will be graduating
from this school and we owe a great debt
to it though even if they managed to
graduate some of us may need to put a
little more time into their studies ah
ha ha ha ha
but those graduates have one thing in
common they're filled with hope for
their future they're ready to challenge
with live ahead tell still our dreams
very good oh-oh okay I'm done D how did
you get into this lecture room wasn't
the hallway look hey you forgot a
graduate here I know all the secret ways
dummy yeah I don't think that's true at
all
what were you listen to a tape yeah for
my graduation day man
it's a billy-ben can we use getting
started with the place and even
abandoned it really hasn't changed it's
just like it was when I was taking
classes studying was wearing me out so I
came up with a breather
it's nice to have placed world members
like this you graduate but you're still
studying Hey lay off yeah I couldn't
pass the bar exam man
so I'm cramming a home now bruh what's
it to you bruh no really he's nothing
he's then that's what he looks like
really that's what he looks like you're
not gonna go oooh bruton okay fine
whatever I'm not making the game but I
will make one soon work was rough and I
barely managed to graduate it's kind of
my kind or think is my kind helpful put
reserge that did it I'll pass next time
for sure I mean there's much time
anymore and I'll be home away by my
classmates yeah whatever man
world's good to be oh well it's good to
be motivated but it's dangerous here you
should get out of here soon
I'm dangerous what there's kind of a
monster that trying to kill you it'll
attack you if it finds you um you know I
thought you were just some weird old guy
wandering an abandoned school but damn
you really are nuts weird huh seriously
a monster even little girls don't
believe that stuff you're being a total
doofus bread
do you enjoy making fun of people and I
don't think I'm much older than you
don't quarrel with me all right
I know big words I'm a talented
soon-to-be lawyer you'd be no match for
me oh do what you want but don't say I
didn't warn you yeah I brewed the what I
like Thanks
like I need a shady Punk like you
telling me what the two around my alma
mater err and yes I'm gonna be using our
voice for him throughout the entire game
so I hope he stays around for a long
time wha really you got him to play it's
cool whoa that's crazy David I can't
even do a handstand you can do whatever
you put your mind to
was it what does a handstand it I think
someone just got into a car accident
outside did you hear that okay anyway
but it doesn't make me a pilot yet I
still have to pass the exam man dude you
totally will be and make sure to give me
a ride I love a fly above the city
sometime Paul I'm not gonna be flying
passengers planes it's not that kind of
school don't what the details man I'm
glad for you you did good hey I'll take
you to lunch today don't do back then I
really wasn't thinking I was just going
wherever I wanted
I wonder if Dee's like that I don't
think that even matters remotely a
little bit Julia Stone school newspapers
posted up a big hand for mikkel Mikkel
stay --them wrote a dissertation
inserted an ad in scholar book okay
birthday six nine I'm writing down
whatever numbers I see so six nine that
could be qualified as oh six one nine
could be knows all right so anyway um it
seems like it's gonna be important so
that's what I'm just doing I'm doing it
all right anyway I am all out of time
for this part I've been playing for
quite a while so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye-bye